Most apps fail not because they look
bad, but because they ignore how people
actually think. The best designers in
the world don't just push pixels. They
understand psychology. And today, I'm
going to show you six psychology
principles that will completely change
the way you design. Every single one
comes with a real before and after, so
you can see exactly what to do
differently. Let's go. Here's something
that sounds obvious, but almost nobody
does. Stop giving users blank forms.
Look at this booking screen. Five
completely empty fields. Every single
one is a decision the user has to make
before anything happens. Psychologists
call this decision fatigue. The more
choices you stack on someone at once,
the more likely they are to make no
choice at all and just leave. A study
from Columbia University found that when
a grocery store displayed 24 jam
flavors, only 3% of people bought one.
When they showed just six, the purchase
rate jumped to 30%. More choices doesn't
mean better. It means harder.
Now look at this version. Same screen,
[music]
same fields, but everything is
pre-filled with the most common choices.
And the button doesn't just say search.
It tells you there are already 12
results waiting. Here's why this works
so well. 70 to 90% of users in most
products never change the default
values. That's not laziness. It's trust.
When you provide a smart default, users
read it as a recommendation. You're
saying, "This is what most people pick."
And that's incredibly persuasive. The
user's job shifts from "Fill this out
from scratch." to "Scan and adjust what
doesn't fit." That's a fundamentally
easier task. So, the principle is called
smart defaults. And the rule is simple.
Pre-select the most common choice for
every field. Don't make users think when
you already know the answer.
This tip will change the way you think
about onboarding entirely. Researchers
at Columbia ran a study at a car wash.
One group of customers got a loyalty
card with eight empty stamps. Fill all
eight, get a free wash. The second group
got a card with 10 stamps, but two were
already filled in. Same eight washes
needed, but the group that started with
two stamps completed the card at nearly
double the rate. That's the goal
gradient effect. The closer people feel
to finishing something, the faster they
move toward it. And the critical insight
is this, you can choose where the
starting line is. Look at this
onboarding screen. 0% complete, five
empty stamps. It's telling the user you
haven't started and there's a lot ahead.
That's deflating, even if the actual
work is minimal. Now, this version. Same
form, same fields, but progress already
shows 20%. The first step is checked
off. The user can see exactly where they
are and how close the finish line is.
They didn't do any extra work. You just
reframed account creation as step one
instead of treating it as a separate
event. 0% feels like standing still. 20%
feels like momentum. And that feeling is
what separates the users who finish
onboarding from the ones who drop off at
the second screen. LinkedIn does this
brilliantly. They show you a profile
strength meter from the moment you sign
up, and it's never at zero. The rule,
[music] never start a user at zero. Find
something they've already done and count
it. That artificial head start creates
real motivation. If you want to get
better at designing onboarding that
actually works,
>> [music]
>> Mobbin is genuinely the best resource
for it. You can study how top teams
design onboarding, upgrades, checkouts,
and other key flows. So, instead of
guessing what good UX looks [music]
like, you can actually see it. In fact,
one of the first things we do before
designing any onboarding flow is go to
Mobbin and search for onboarding.
Instantly, you can see real examples
from top products, which makes it much
easier to find inspiration and see what
good patterns look like in practice.
It's a simple trick that helps you
design better and faster. And if you
want to try it, too, you can get 20% off
using the special link in the
description. So far, we've talked about
making things easier or making things
urgent. But if the user doesn't trust
you yet, none of it matters. Most apps
ask for something before they give
anything. Sign up to see your results.
Create an account to continue. Enter
your email to unlock. The user hasn't
received a single thing of value and
already the app wants something from
them. Look at the screen. The user
entered their URL, hit analyze, waited
for the scan, and now the results are
blurred out behind a lock. Create an
account to see your report. Think about
what that communicates. You're holding
the results hostage. It's like a
restaurant asking for your credit card
before they show you the menu. You'd
walk out, and that's exactly what users
do here. Now this approach. The user
hits analyze and actually gets a real
report. Not the full thing, but enough
to be genuinely useful. Their score,
their top issues, what passed. They can
already see what's wrong with their site
and start thinking about fixes. And then
at the bottom, a simple [music] prompt.
Want the complete breakdown with
step-by- step instructions? Save your
report. The difference in conversion is
massive because of a principle called
[music] reciprocity. When someone gives
you something first, you feel a pull to
return the favor. It's not rational.
It's one of the deepest human instincts
we have. Robert Cialdini spent his
career studying persuasion and ranked
this as the single most powerful driver
of human behavior. It's why free samples
at grocery stores increase purchases by
up to 2,000%.
>> [music]
>> The sample isn't that good, but
receiving it creates an unconscious
debt. Every smart company uses this.
Costco gives you free samples. Spotify
gives you 30 days of premium. Notion
lets you use the entire product before
you ever pay. They're not being
generous. They're being strategic. The
sign up never feels like a wall because
the user already got something worth
coming back for. Have you ever spent an
afternoon assembling IKEA furniture and
then thought, "Actually, this looks
pretty good." It objectively doesn't
look that different from what you'd buy
pre-assembled, But, it feels different
because you built it. You spent time on
it, and that labor changed how you value
it. Researchers actually studied this
and gave it a name, the IKEA effect.
When people build something themselves,
they value it significantly more than an
identical item someone else made.
There's an even simpler version of this
called the endowment effect. You don't
even have to build something. Just
feeling like you own it is enough. Now,
think about what most sign-up pages do.
Email, password, sign up. There's
nothing on this screen that belongs to
the user. They haven't created anything.
They haven't chosen anything. Closing
the tab is effortless because there's
nothing to lose. Now, look at this
approach. The user hasn't signed up yet,
but they're already building. They're
choosing their name, their title, their
color palette, their card style. Every
choice makes this feel more like theirs,
and the button at the bottom doesn't say
sign up, it says continue because by
now, leaving doesn't feel like skipping
a form. It feels like abandoning
something they made. Duolingo does this
brilliantly. Before you ever create an
account, you've already picked your
language, set your goal, and completed
your first lesson. By the time the
sign-up screen appears, you've invested
10 minutes. You're not going to throw
that away. That's not manipulation.
That's smart design. You're giving
people a reason to stay by letting them
build something worth staying for.
Most designers are still learning UX and
UI the old way. They watch another
tutorial on how to recreate a beautiful
app screen, add a smooth Figma
interaction, or create another glass
effect. And yes, those things can
[music] be useful, but they're not what
gets you hired at serious product
companies because interviewers are not
just looking for someone who can make a
screen look nice. They want to see how
you think. They want to see if you
understand user psychology, conversion,
retention, business impact, and why
certain design decisions actually work.
That's why we created UX Peak Plus. UX
Peak Plus teaches the advanced UX and UI
skills most designers are missing. We
break down how top companies design
product pages,
onboarding flows,
pricing pages,
mobile apps, SaaS products, and
high-converting experiences. So, you can
understand not just what looks good, but
what actually works. It's the kind of
knowledge you can use in your case
studies, portfolio, interviews, and real
product work. You can start for free at
uxpeak.com with the free course. And if
you decide to join UX Peak Plus, use
code UX [music] Peak 20 to get 20% off
with our launch offer. You also have a
7-day money-back guarantee. So, there is
no risk. Now, let's get into the next
tip.
All right, that was about making users
feel invested. But, what about
motivation? What makes someone actually
act instead of tapping maybe later?
Daniel Kahneman won a Nobel Prize for
proving that the pain of losing
something is psychologically twice as
powerful as the pleasure of gaining the
same thing. Twice. Think about what that
means for product design. Every time you
frame a feature as something users could
gain, you're using the weaker motivator.
Look at the screen, a storage app
offering a premium upgrade. Nice icon,
nice feature list, nice button, upgrade
now. And below it, the world's easiest
escape hatch, maybe later. There's
nothing at stake, nothing changes if the
user ignores this. The screen has zero
psychological weight. Now, this version,
same product, same goal. But, instead of
selling what the user could have, it
shows what the user is about to lose,
their actual files, by name, with the
countdown. And the dismiss option
doesn't let you off easy, it says, "I'll
risk it." The first screen is a pitch,
the second screen is a threat, and
threat wins every time because of a
concept called the status quo bias.
[music] Humans are wired to protect what
they already have. You need to make them
feel the cost of inaction. So, here's
the takeaway, [music]
whenever you're designing a screen that
asks users to act, flip the framing.
Don't sell what they'll gain, show what
they'll lose if they don't.
Last one is a principle that why the
exact same price can feel expensive or
feel like nothing. Look at the screen. A
protection plan shown on its own page,
$50 a month. The user sees that number
in isolation and does a quick mental
calculation, $600
a year. That's a lot. They hit no thanks
and move on.
Now look at the same offer in a
different context. [music] The user just
added a $1900 laptop to their cart and
directly below the product, the
protection plan appears. Same $50, but
now there's a small label next to it,
just 2.6%. Nothing changed about the
offer. Everything changed about how it
feels. After seeing $1900, $50 barely
registers. Your brain isn't doing an
absolute evaluation anymore. It's doing
a relative one. And it's relative to the
price you just processed, this is a
rounding error. This is the contrast
effect. Your brain evaluates every piece
of information relative to the thing it
saw immediately before. Restaurants use
this constantly. They put a $90 Wagyu
steak on the menu not because many
people order it, but because it makes
the $40 salmon look like a reasonable
choice. Real estate agents show you a
slightly overpriced house first so the
one they actually want to sell feels
like a deal.
>> [music]
>> For designers, the rule is don't show a
cost in isolation. Always control what
the user sees first because that first
number becomes the ruler they measure
everything else against.
So those are the six UX psychology
principles. And if you zoom out, they
all share the same insight. Your users
aren't making logical decisions.
Defaults feel like recommendations. The
first number sets the anchor. A gift
creates a debt. Building something makes
it yours. And progress, even a fake one,
creates real momentum. The designers who
get this build products people can't
stop using. The ones who don't build
products people forget exist. Thanks for
watching. We'll see you in the next one.